welcome back Cristiano Ronaldo's pittery
for joining Saudi Arabia's al-nasa team
and the biggest money dealer football
history he'd sold out they said at worst
he trashed his legacy by Sports washing
the brutal Saudi regime Lionel Messi we
were sure would never do that and that
looks like Messi he closed his rival and
the greatest of all time contest
although I think Ronaldo edges him will
be following him to the desert Kingdom
reports suggests the World Cup winner is
about to sign a 500 million pound deal
with the rival team al-hillau so are
these Legends Sports washing a brutal
regime or are they just banking the
bumper payday they deserve after
stunning careers and doing what many
footballers done going and playing in a
different country at the Twilight end of
their of their football lives of
drumming as a boxing promoter Frank
Warren and by the human rights lawyer
and former managing director of these
United David Hagel welcome to both of
you Frank it's a very emotive issue this
I remember when Ronaldo obviously I
remember it because I'd done the
interview which led to him going there
but
um I interviewed Cristiano that's why he
Jeff United ends up going to Saudi
Arabia a lot of Messi fans mocking this
now probably having to eat their words
because it's like Messi may be following
Ronaldo because the money is simply
stratospherically higher than these guys
could get anywhere else in the world at
this stage in their careers are they
doing anything morally wrong
no I don't think so I think if you first
of all you've got to look at the
situation that you know last year our
elected government and the prime
minister is elected at the time Boris
Johnson if you remember when there was
all the oil prices were shooting up very
high he went over to Saudi to try and do
a deal for oil for us you know we have
companies over here in the UK who who
trade on a daily basis providing arms uh
uh airplanes cars everything to Saudi so
a sportsman who has a very short
lifespan or in his career you can't
blame them at the end of day for going
there I don't you know it's a question
of their morals but and again you look
back you go back to the 60s I can
remember all the English players going
to South Africa and when the apartheid
was right on lots of them were going now
yeah well David hey my issue with this
whole Sports washing debate and we had
all this over the World Cup in Qatar
it's just this stinking hypocrisy
whichever way you look everyone who puts
on their moral Halo including by the way
our country which last time I checked it
legally invaded Rock in 2003 what right
do we have frankly to cast moral
aspersions on other countries and
players taking their business there
given that we let them play here when we
did something like that
well good evening Pez I mean I certainly
agree with you there is there is an
awful lot of Human Rights hypocrisy in
in football as well when you look at how
we deal with for instance Russians
owning football clubs at the moment
compared to to to to golf dictatorships
and you know that's something that you
see and you know I agree with with Frank
when he says you can't blame people like
Lionel Messi for going to these
countries but as a human rights lawyer
of course I mean I would want them to
use the fact that they are going there
to help improve the human rights records
in those countries and cast a a
spotlight on the human rights abuses of
which there are many but do you not
think that people like Ronaldo are Messi
um because of their Global Fame and
they're two of the most followed people
on social media in the world Ronaldo's
number one and I think Messi's number
two on Instagram that just by going
there and living there and playing sport
there they cast an unbelievable light on
these countries we saw that with Qatar
and so in a way just by being there
these guys with their profile they do go
quite a long way to highlighting other
issues don't they
they do I mean that's that that's I
think one of the benefits that you get
from um players going to countries like
this and from the the what we saw in the
Qatar World Cup but I think that's a
smaller one you've also got to I think
look at the fact that you know the
people that are being abused in Saudi
and and other countries you know and and
how they feel because at the end of the
day you know is we can debate this you
know it's Lionel Messi's football worth
half a billion for a couple of years
that's not a commercial decision in
terms of a football commercial decision
it's Edition by Saudi to effectively
sportswash their their human rights
abuses well actually you see I again I
take it I take issue with that because
you know I know a lot about the Ronaldo
deal and everything I I don't really
think that's what they're paying for
they're paying to grow football in Saudi
which we know from the Qatar World Cup
how well a lot of football in that
region is now going at teams like
Morocco and others they want to grow
Saudi football to make them proper World
players I really don't think that their
main reason for doing this and paying
these guys all this money money is to
sports wash their regime or to somehow
improve the world's view of their human
rights I think it's simply they want to
make Saudi and other countries in the
Middle East
top of the world for putting on sport
I think it's you know it's it's
absolutely true I mean let me bring in
Frank yeah Frank you got you answered
that one
yeah sorry I you know I feel that's
right it's not just football I mean
they've they've invested very heavily in
golf Formula One WWE they've had boxing
now there is sports and it's all
reinvestment I mean to get someone to go
there you're going to have to pay them a
premium at this stage until it becomes a
destination and that's that's a fact of
life but there's for example the um
formula one has paid off hasn't it
they've done they've got they've got a
The Whole World's eyes are on that and
big boxing events and so forth yeah
right from a pure football point of view
Frank the cattle World Cup Saudi Arabia
beat the world champions Argentina in
the World Cup they're the only team to
do so so there's no doubt that the
quality of football I know from
Cristiano in in Saudi he's been very
impressed by the general quality of the
football there and the fans are really
fanatical and I just again I come back
to this this issue I have with the
hypocrisy once you put morality at the
center stage of where people comply
their trade in sport well where do you
end up going I mean seriously where do
you end up going I mean David you're a
gay man and you've talked you've done a
lot of good work in that area in terms
of LGBT rights and so on I think it was
something like a quarter of all the
teams in the World Cup finals uh came
from countries which ban homosexuality
for example do you not have any
tournaments in Africa for example at all
because of their record in individual
countries on gay rights in other words
it's complicated it's not as easy as it
may seem to people sitting here in
England
yeah no I agree with that I think like
as I said it's like you know you've got
considerable human rights hypocrisy and
and I don't think it's it's not possible
and it's perhaps not the right thing to
do to try and regulate individual
players going to you know for their
retirement whatever it may be to
whatever country you're never going to
be able to do that they'll be a you know
there'll be more people doing it
there'll be more players but there are
areas in sports watching that we can
regulate and we saw recently with the
Premier League introducing uh what they
said would be new laws and new
regulations on the owners and directors
tests to Stamp Out dictators and despots
buying into English football I think
there's something that we can actually
try and improve the situation you know
should Nations like Saudi be able to buy
football you will have yeah to counter
that you will have people in the Middle
East who say that all the American
owners buying into the Premier League
well what's the difference they say they
are legally invaded Iraq like the UK did
they've done other stuff which they
believe abuses human rights as they
think the UK has as well it depends
where you are in the world as to how you
view these things you know when I was in
Canada
really struck by how angry they were
about all the hypocrisy about human
rights not to defend their own issues
they just say well who's who's actually
pointing the finger at us who's so
morally pure
I think that's the issue that you've got
and you know even you know how do you
judge and the football league uh the
sorry the Premier League in England have
said that they're gonna they're gonna
decide whether or not someone is a human
rights abuse or on the basis of them
being on that our equivalent of the
minitsky sanction list and and then you
look at who's on it and there's
effectively no one that perhaps should
be so you know it's a very difficult
thing to say who is a human rights
abuser and who isn't who's the judge and
jury of that so you know whether you
look at sportswashing in in terms of
buying football clubs or players going
to these countries it's very very
difficult but one would hope that people
that have a platform you know I had a
platform that leads and I try to improve
you know um inclusivity and diversity
and and LGB rights and football 10 years
ago
um and one would hope but that's a
personal thing that people like Messi
and Ronaldo would use their platform to
do that and and you know that's that
that's that thing you'll never be able
to force them to do that or not
are saying you also you look at the
demographic of Saudi Arabia I think it's
nearly 60 percent of the population are
under the age of 40. yeah so you've got
a younger generation there and the fact
these guys are going there they're
opening their eyes up to what is
happening and obviously you know as you
say Ronaldo Messi and many other people
are quite tolerant in their views and
and hopefully that will reflect in the
future I think that is a really
significant Point honestly I do I think
these guys aren't going to change their
views from what I've seen so far their
views are very well known they're all
shared on Instagram every day so the
fact they're over there shining a light
and it could work both ways actually
um Frank I can't let you go without
asking are we going to win the Premier
League Arsenal
oh God I'll tell you what I'm on the
edge that we we fell over on those three
three uh matches which uh I I I was like
torture but how impressive were they on
on they were brilliant but give me some
hopeless are we gonna win Frank
I'm I'm I've got my I'm praying I'm from
everybody you know we've we all want it
to happen well man city got fall over
haven't they for us they've got to fall
over they got they've got to lose lose
and draw one yeah that's a big ass it's
absolute agony isn't it uh Frank great
to see you David thank you very much I
appreciate it thanks guys thanks peers